Donald Trump won the election in 2016 vowing to build a wall to deport all unauthorized residents
and to massively reduce the number of people welcomed here legally.
COVID-19, which has its origins in Wuhan China, may help the President to deliver fully
on those campaign promises. Is the mythology of America as a nation of immigrants coming to an end?
I can't point to an incident, in American history at least, where financial and economic collapse led to
a Kumbaya feeling, where everyone is like oh you're different from me that's okay.
A deputy national editor at the New York Times, Jia Lynn Yang, is the author of the timely new book,
"One Mighty and Irresistible Tide: The Epic Struggle over American Immigration, 1924 to 1965.
The book begins at another dark moment in American immigration policy
when a restrictive law ended a long period of relatively open borders and effectively stopped mass movement
to the United States. It tells the story of the decades-long battle that led the US to begin accepting foreigners
once again, and yet nobody involved in that fight foresaw the extent to which the 1965 law,
signed by President Lyndon Johnson, would open the door once again to new immigrants,
including Yang's family, which came here from Taiwan in the 1970's.
Our beautiful America was built by a nation of strangers. From a hundred different places or more
they have poured forth into an empty land, joining and blending in one mighty and irresistible tide.
I sat down with Yang in our studio in early March and then more recently in May
to discuss what her book and personal story can teach us about the current moment.
It's a pleasure to talk to you Jia Lynn, thanks for speaking with Reason.
You have a personal connection to immigration particularly the laws of the period
that your book covers, what is it? So my family would not be here if not for the 1965 Immigration
and Nationality Act. And when I began working on this whole project I'd never heard of the law, never been
taught in high school or college I just
been told like I think a lot of American
families the the Ghazi story of how we
ended up here at all
and basically my family's from China and
after the Civil War and the Communists
won in 1949 my grandparents all left for
Taiwan like a lot of other refugees and
then my parents grew up there and then
came to the US in the 60s and 70s for
college and grad school and that's how
we came here and then we have cousins
aunts everyone's here that was always
the very Pat glowing story and we're a
nation of immigrants so everybody ends
up so of course we were allowed to come
here right and growing up my friends
also you know their parents were from
Iran Afghanistan Poland all over the
world
I just took for granted that if your
family wanted to come here it sounds
naive now to say that given especially
right now how much we're debating who
can come in and who can't but for my own
family I just like we're immigrants this
country's always wanted immigrants were
Chinese they're all these Chinese
Americans around obviously we're here so
let's talk about American immigration
policy and you know just too bright
let's say from the beginning of the
Republic up through 1880 1882
what was the what was the immigration
policy and then what changed right
around then our immigration policy was
quite open we needed people to come and
colonize this land and so we were very
open if you basically wanted to show up
we didn't have visas there were no
passports
there wasn't border control if you got
here and this was true until really the
1920s
if you got here and you made it
physically this long long journey you
could be here
naturalization we did have in 1790 the
founders lay down the only people
eligible for naturalization were free
whites and so that was one restriction
but really we didn't have people from
Asia in the Middle East the way we do
now so this seemed it was all European
right although in the 1880s the Chinese
Exclusion Act came about and you know
this is I mean it's it's disturbing to
think about it now but they certainly
were not hiding the ball what was what
was the function of that and how did
that change immigration so in 1882 the
US has for the first time in immigration
law restricting
people coming and based on their
ethnicity we had not done that before
and this was fueled by a huge anti-asian
backlash against Chinese laborers in
particular so it was a particular class
of immigrants coming
it wasn't diplomats or teachers or
educated people it was workers and so in
1882 we banned all Chinese laborers and
from that point on you can see that were
as a country slowly but surely adding
more and more restrictions in 1917 a big
federal law is passed but again it's
still a fairly porous situation you know
we want literacy to some degree but if
you're literate in a language that's not
English that's fine too
you know very very few people are turned
away from the border and at this point
you're talking about people flooding
into Ellis Island again tons of you
still more European immigrants southern
Eastern Europe and that's who's coming
and we're mainly allowing them but you
are seeing from the Chinese Exclusion
Act we're beginning by race to decide if
we want your and then there was a later
kind of addendum which I guess was not
an official immigration policy but that
excluded Japanese yes so when the
Chinese laborers are banned these rail
companies these farms they still need
people to work work these jobs and so
other cheap Asian labor essentially
arrives including a lot of Japanese
immigrants this sets off a whole new
wave of kind of anti Asian backlash in
particular on the west coast and so the
u.s. and Japan have an agreement that
basically it's not so formal it's not
pass through the Senate but it says it's
called the gentlemen's agreement it says
why don't you just do your best to keep
people from coming from Hawaii a lot of
Japanese immigrants are going there from
coming to the mainland and that takes
whole two so you just see their efforts
to basically as they see Asian
immigrants come begin to sort of stem
that tide but meanwhile you know Eastern
and Southern European immigrant eel from
Italy Russia they're pouring into the
country and that's what triggers so
there's massive yes in 1924 that's when
I mean there had been as you were
mentioning there were a couple of other
laws leading up to that but in 1924 what
what changes in immigration policy they
look at the entire system and they
reshape it in ways that change the
country forever they basically say you
know based on eugenics and
they're experts who tell them you know
we're studying all these different
ethnicities in fact they didn't even
have this idea of ethnic is not really
how they're working and this time when
they think of race they think of kind of
what we consider international so it
southern Italians were one ranked
northern Italians another Hebrew is a
race these are all different races of
people and oh look we're scientists
we're gonna study each of these races
and to tell you well this race you know
is it's not all bad things it's it could
be something positive about you know
aliens were very good with their hey I
say this because I'm part Italian so I
came but they were good with their hands
and they were dumb but hard laborers if
they weren't anarchists and bomb
throwers right but then also prone to
criminality and they sort of you know
they well that's when I was true but it
would claim to go into prisons and you
know mental health institutions and
basically say like we see a lot of
people from Poland here that tells us
that if you're so great but I mean we're
Jews early on you know what score you
know in the idiot range on IQ tests and
then somehow so we didn't let them in
but then you know ten years later
they're they're flooding Ivy League
institutions we need quotas against yes
yes sorry an exam yes but everyone is
making I mean it's a fake science of
course but they're going through and and
coming up with these really big hefty
reports saying we have catalogued all of
the entire human humankind by these
races and we've decided there are some
people that just shouldn't be coming
into this country because to allow them
in would be to change the gene pool of
this country and would change our
bloodlines it would threaten our ability
to be a democracy right what if we're
inviting people in who just don't get
democracy because their race you know
I've never heard that argument ever
uttered and you know in recent memory so
in nineteen twenty four or as a result
of the twenty four law though and and
this is also jerry-rigged where the
number of people who are legally led
into the country from certain European
countries it's pegged to the 1890 census
as a way of keeping out you know the the
Jews and the Italians and the poles the
southern and central Europeans in
particular but you right at one point
that in 1925 total arrivals plummeted
d eight percent from the year before
from more than 700,000 to fewer than
300,000 so this is like a real gate
coming now
yes this is transformative you have
steamships coming right before this
coming into Ellis Island and again these
are levels of immigration that are
totally historic like New York is just
transformed overnight right right you go
from let's say 14,000 or so Russian Jews
to nearly half a million in the span of
just a few decades so the city is is
transformed forever but once these gates
come down all of that really stops right
and then a couple years later the
depression hits which tamps things down
then there's world war two yeah your
book is talking about that period from
you know the 1924 act until the 1965 act
which is the first major overhaul of
immigration and in decades but with some
tinkering that we'll get to so then what
what starts happening after nineteen you
know in 1925 to say like about 1950 what
what's going on with immigration policy
because we do have a world war and we
have a lot of refugees we have a lot of
displaced people suddenly China which
had been kind of this antagonist because
was sending over these coolies who were
you know could work like machines and so
we didn't want that but then you know
after World War two that turns to you
know Communist China is suddenly you
know that's a bad thing and we want to
be friendly with Taiwan and other
Chinese like how does all how do
geopolitics change or complicate
immigration policy say from 1925 to
about 1950 fifty-five if you imagine the
1920s as being a very isolationist very
you know pro-american nationalist time
where people are sort of we're literally
closing off border is it's very inward
looking World War two changes all of
that
right well beyond immigration the idea
of the United States being on the world
stage having these very deep moral
obligations to other countries around
the world and so as we're fighting this
war it becomes clear that our
immigration laws don't match in many
ways our foreign policy so one very
tangible example is you know in 1882
that Chinese Exclusion Act banned also
the naturalization of anyone
Chinese so again something I took for
granted
my parents naturalized and became
American citizens that wasn't allowed
and you know starting 1882 but during
the war the Chinese are our allies and
it seems embarrassing and downright
insulting to signal to our ally we don't
actually think that you're you're up to
you know up to snuff to be citizens and
so we allow Chinese immigrants to
naturalize we slowly crack the door open
to Chinese immigration we allow about a
hundred people of Chinese descent to
come in not very generous but it's
symbolic right it's saying oh this is
actually pretty pretty retrograde we
can't do this it's it's in conflict with
our foreign policy and then in addition
to that you see of course during the
Holocaust there is this massive refugee
crisis and you have people and Jews and
Eastern Europe all trying to come to the
US and this is where we begin to see
well you can't really admit any of these
people because you've just passed these
quotas saying we don't know what want
anyone from this part of the world and
so there begin to be lawmakers some one
manís seller Brooklyn congressman from
New York not well-known but I'd argue
just one of the one of the like most
powerful Democrats and we local
lawmakers ever we will get to him in a
second because he's the hero of your
book and virtually all books about
immigration in the 20th century yeah yep
what what happened to the racial dogmas
because this is also you know and
somebody like Daniel Okrent and last
year's the guarded gate talks about how
the Nazis actually looked at the race
science that was being used to fix
American for immigration policy in the
early 20th century was adopted by the
Nazis we fight the Nazis we beat the
Nazis we realize you know maybe their
race science wasn't such a good idea
after all how does that change the way
that we talk about immigration because
there's still a lot of racism and
xenophobia going on so this whole idea
in the 20s where eugenics was as
all-powerful science once we begin to
fight Nazi Germany becomes clear that
they are basing all of their horrors on
this terrible race science we of course
begin to very much back away from it
so on the hill when immigration is
discussed people are really saying like
well I don't I don't really believe in
eugenics obviously and Truman who's
president this time and I'd argue a kind
of a little-known figure in the history
of immigration you don't think of him as
a big figure in it but he's an
incredibly important linchpin in this
whole thing because he's inherited this
unfinished war from FDR right and he is
looking at the refugee crisis at all of
this bunk science that's powered these
really racist quotas under immigration
he says none of this makes any sense and
we have to if we're gonna fight this war
we're gonna win it on moral terms our
immigration policy isn't is immoral as
well right it reflects this race science
and it has to be changed so he is the
first one really in the White House in
American history to begin saying we need
a formal refugee policy because our
immigration policy is so it's so hostile
right now to changing these quotas to
letting these people in we need a
separate kind of way of saying hey if
you have you know a political reason
that you need safe harbor we're gonna
allow you to come so even this idea that
we take for granted now if you're gonna
have a sponsor right like a lot of
christian groups or nonprofits will
sponsor refugee this begins at our
Truman and in 1948 he signs essentially
the first refugee act in federal history
this is I mean he's also thoughtful
because geopolitically a lot of the
people that we need us as allies in the
Cold War are people who come from
countries that we were like no we don't
like your kind whether it's Japan Korea
or parts of Europe in the early 50s
there's something called the McCarran
Walter act which is one of the first it
really the most significant change in
immigration policy since the 20s what
was in that how did how did
Truman respond and then what happened
next so the 1952 law is this huge
basically it's a way of redoing
potentially the 1920s law right so if
that was this big you know country
altering law 1950s is a chance for
everyone all sides of this to come
together and say how do we feel about
those laws and how they've worked and
how much do we want to change them and
so there is a huge
huge fight basically where a lot of
these people coming out of the Holocaust
world we're to saying okay enough is
enough these laws are clearly racist and
bad we've got to change them but you
have during this time as well it's the
Cold War and McCarthyism is at full full
force and often in our history when
people are anti-immigrant it's also
mixed up in anti radical anti communist
ideas and so the sense of well we don't
really want to change our immigration
laws too much because we don't want
these people coming in who are radicals
who are spies we're gonna undermine it
I'm sorry I'm laughing because it is
like when you start to think about it so
it's when the Soviet Union starts
pushing into Eastern Europe and say
Polish people want to leave because
they're anti-communist were like hey
right
you know we're anti-communist but we
really don't want you because you might
be a secret communist that's why you're
fleeing from communism so get out but
maybe we got I mean it just it's a very
complicated kind of set of mental
gymnastics that anti immigrant people
are trying to maintain it's a lot of
things coming together at once it's it's
the nativism that we see so much in our
American history of just like those
people are different they could be
subversive you know we have a lot of
still very anti-semitic anti-catholic to
some degree still during this time but
then you have yeah this cross current of
oh but we're fighting this ideological
war we want people to come who don't
want funny natural Liberty and it's been
recast not as you know a monument from
France about the Enlightenment but it's
this you know wretched refuse because
yeah and this is also during the time
you know we also imagine that we've
always thought of ourselves as a nation
of immigrants the 1950s is when that
mythology actually becomes begins
getting born and it's during these
debates right so people are fighting
against these McCarthy asuras he sort of
Xena continued to xenophobia and they're
saying hey look like everyone who's here
in this country came because of some
immigrant you know their parents their
grandparents or great-grandparents let's
begin to celebrate that history and you
see JFK writing a pamphlet called a
nation of immigrants you see actually
immigration historians this is a new
area of history and study so let's well
let's talk first about JFK because I'm
half Italian and I'm half
and I did I just dislike JFK in general
and he is a minor figure in this in your
book but an interesting one because the
Kennedys were Irish they were Irish
Catholic and that was young part of
their identity but they kind of fudged
that as much as they could because to be
Irish and Catholic and the early part of
the 20th century wasn't necessarily a
social benefit yeah as you were saying
he puts his name on a pamphlet but he
also he voted for the McCarran Walther
act which was this anti-communist kind
of anti-immigrant Act and then he voted
when Truman Truman vetoed it and
Congress overrode the veto what's going
on with Jack Kennedy and how does how
does the Kennedy you know experience of
John F Kennedy going from being kind of
a wannabe Boston Brahmin blueblood you
know oh I'd like maybe I came over on
the Mayflower to being kind of
aggressively Irish Catholic what does
that say about what's going on in
post-war America he's a fat joe he's
fascinating in all this right because he
basically and also because not only did
he not write the pamphlet he probably
never even read it just like I he may
have reviewed it it's not it's not clear
but like some of his other works yeah so
I won't get into you know there's some
questions around how closely he was you
know the pendants yeah let's not get too
technical it eclis it's a big moment for
him because he's launching this career
and being a Kennedy he's got a lot of
money but he's very young doesn't
actually have a lot of experience but he
launches his career out of Boston he
runs for Congress and there's this great
moment I remember finding in this oral
history of an italian-american worked on
his campaign where he shows up in the
district that he wants to represent he
barely knows this district really okay
his grandparents grew up in these you
know tiny streets of the north end but
JFK is from Palm Beach he's like he
doesn't know his way around north and he
I think you point out that when he when
he lived in England when his father was
the ambassador to the UK he didn't even
visit him gonna Ireland this idea that
they're Irish is like they've really
tried to sort of wasp over the whole
thing so this this italian-american is
taking around the North End and JFK
clearly has just never been there
doesn't
barely barely knows it but he's got to
convince all these people in these
working-class Irish tiny neighborhoods
to vote for him and so suddenly he now
this whole thing that his family's been
trying to sort of paper over and sort of
I'd argue really make as like a minor
footnote in who they are now has to be
come to the fore because if he wants to
get elected he's got to relate to these
people and he does have this incredible
family history with his mom's father
honey Fitz who was a mayor of Boston
sort of a beloved you know Irish
American figure and so JFK has to sort
of bring himself closer to that part of
his family and sort of I would argue
make himself seem more Irish to attract
these people and one of the best ways
you can signal to ethnic voters that I'm
on your side is through immigration
policy and to say I see your family
these are immigrants and I'm gonna try
to change the laws so that more of your
relatives can come where people like you
you you all make this country great and
so he begins from that point on to
really make immigration part of his
platform and at the early time so he
votes for the McCarran Walter Act
because he also is quite hawkish on
communism you know his father is friends
with McCarthy himself he is pretty you
know let's let's go a little bit deeper
opportunity worked for Joe McCarthy Joe
McCarthy is the godparent of his yes the
family is very tied to my person and
very I mean by very anti-communist yes
and again it's these it's these it's
this Irish Catholic a connection that
McCarthy you know it's funny I you know
obviously Catholic but I I'm kind of
like I don't want him to be an Irish
calf he's from the Midwest but these are
like up-and-coming Irish Catholic
politicians right and so Joe can be
senior I I would think probably thinks
that McCarthy's just he's one of them
they're power-hungry Irish Catholics who
want you know power in Washington and
they're very anti-communist and JFK's
political ideas I'd also argue at this
time are kind of fuzzy but on this he's
very clear he's very anti-communist he's
very into foreign policy but he slowly
has to learn about immigration policy
and so this is why he writes this
pamphlet when he gets to the White House
he's run on this as well but he wants to
overturn these quotas so he begins to
actually put forward legislation dealing
with this
of course he's assassinated but I'd
argue that if he had not put forward
this legislation and then LBJ doesn't
run with it we wouldn't have had these
reforms to before we get to that act and
his brother than Ted Kennedy has a big
role in in the 1965 Act but you
mentioned historians and the 50s kind of
remaking America recasting the American
narrative as an immigrant narrative
Oscar Hamlin is one of the historians
that you write a lot about already talk
a lot about what was his role in and you
know and this is something I you know it
happens all the time where we think you
know that America has always been this
way
you know the American Renaissance II
suppose it flowering of lighters in the
early 19th century particularly emboss
and was something that was created in
the 1920s and 30s but a couple of
literary historians in a similar way
Oscar Hamlin kind of recreates America
casts it back as an immigrant story who
was he and what how did he transform the
way we talk about American philosophy
Canon is is Jewish families from Eastern
Europe and he essentially is the father
of this whole idea of American
immigration history he writes I'm
paraphrasing but in in the beginning of
the bruited which was a very popular
book at the time when a Pulitzer he
basically says I set out to learn
American history what I learned is
American history is the history of
American immigrants that you can't study
American history without looking at the
immigrant experience as being core to
being American before this you know I
was reading recently our idea of what
that mythology was was sort of the
American West that that was the
foundational idea of what of what we are
as a nation
but Oscar Hamlin really makes it into no
no it's not just the West
it's immigrants and he really he writes
this book the uprooted which is an
unusual book it's a very strange work of
history it basically is a sort of
lyrically written book talking about
sort of the experience of immigrants the
very difficult experience that
immigrants have when they come to this
country that it's quite hard to
assimilate and to adjust make a life
here he also that was not just a
historian he is also politically active
so when Truman is furious of the
McCarran Walter act passes and starts a
commission
saying let's figure out how to get rid
of this whole law you know we don't just
pass but let's try to get rid of it
handlin is involved in that too so he's
not only studying the history and
popularizing the history he's also
involved in discussions of hey that
nineteen these 1920s quotas are anti
like their unamerican and we need to
change them and he's part of that effort
so they're fusing a political effort
with this mythology yeah and that's I
mean that is a brilliant rhetorical
gesture because in fact that wasn't an
American it was kind of the quintessence
of America to be restriction estándar
keeping people out merely because they
come from bad countries that is what's
on America yeah it's like it's new
nationalism right I think we tend to
think of nationalism as closing off the
borders but because of this new idea of
a nation of immigrants this phrase that
people like Hanlin and JFK put forward
there's a new nationalism right but like
what makes us great as a country is that
we are we're descended from immigrants
and but this idea is only for the 1950s
but it begins to really become
politically powerful so it's deployed it
doesn't quite win the day in the 1952
debate I'm in the McCarran Walter act
but by the time you get to 65 the the
intervening years this idea takes on
greater and greater power and basically
propels this reform through yep so now
let's talk about Emanuel Celler because
this is a guy who as a congressman it's
like he was you know when the pilgrims
showed up he was already in office and
he he'd lasted all the way through the
early Watergate period I'm Dennis I mean
literally he was in office from like the
1920s of the 20s to the early seventies
yeah and he is really kind of the hero
of this book is he is also in many ways
the hero of Daniel Okrent the guarded
gate I mean he is you know I mean he's a
fascinating figure and talk about him as
we moved to a discussion of the 1965
reform that really is still the
immigration policy yeah more or less
than we're living with but Emanuel
Celler many seller is a total product of
immigrant America right and he is the
grandson of German Jewish immigrants
from the mid-1800s so it's a big wave of
German and Irish immigration mid-1800s
followed by
you know again the Italians Eastern
years and there was also earlier there
was that the kind of Nordic Scandinavian
are Swedes for a while we're like the
most popular immigrant group which is
kind of hilarious yes and all these
group sites essentially assembly we
didn't take for granted worth like he's
from that wave right and what's
interesting is that there's a real
distinction among Jewish immigrants and
children river currents between the
German Jews and the Eastern European
ones who come later man easily
represents this district in Brooklyn is
just filled with immigrants right people
from all over Europe when he's elected
and someone says you know where are your
constituents from he points to a map of
Europe and says they're from Europe it's
this from all over and he loves that he
loves it that's Brooklyn it's his family
and so when he gets into Congress right
away he's these 1920s quotas are passed
and he's horrified he's a very young
congressman he kind of hates Washington
at first because you know when you
joined the house at the beginning you
have no power you're put on these
nothing subcommittees and so he really
has to slowly work his way up
but his tenure in Congress which goes
from you know he joins when Harding is
the president all the way to Nixon
basically he he sees the entire thing
change on immigration from start to
finish right and he's a big part of it
he actually is the reason a big reason
why the law is change so through the
Holocaust and World War two he's
fighting to open up the borders were her
refugees through the 50s and that big
fight he's fighting and then through the
60s he never stops fighting because in
his mind it's people like his family
it's his constituents the laws are
basically insulting and unjust because
they say you're type of people are
inferior to the wasps and the Nordics
that we want and he basically spends his
entire legislative career trying to
change these laws so what happened in
the early sixties I you know and part of
it is Kennedy you know identifies as an
immigrant and then Kennedy gets
assassinated but what what are the kind
of political steps are the things that
have to happen that then we get to a
major reform in the mid 60s so when JFK
dies his entire legislative agenda comes
back to life under the hands of LBJ so
this is being imagined that's not just
immigration right it's really all of the
Great Society reforms that LBJ puts
forward Medicare Medicaid Voting Rights
Act so
right SEC it's all kind of swept in
through all of that and essentially by
the time you get to the sixties the
groundwork has been laid for these
changes and so in a way people aren't
attending to the details of it that much
it's taken on so much symbolism it's
this idea of we're a nation of
immigrants right that mythology's
established now and oh these these
quotas are so racist we can't have them
we can't tell Italians and Jews people
are part of the Democratic base right at
this point and the GOP wants these but
we can't tell these people that they're
in fear so we have to change these laws
by the time LBJ comes in and is sort of
looking at the unfinished legislative
agenda of JFK immigration is on that
list and he gets behind it it's not his
biggest priority and it doesn't seem to
occupy that much you know mindshare
right of the population one of the ways
that Ted Kennedy who ended up being one
of the major pushers of the bill was
saying that okay we're shifting from
country of origin as the big determinant
to family reunification yeah what you
know what what how why is that a better
selling point and then what kind of
happens with that so they're debating
the details right and one of the things
they talk about is well when you look at
priority of who gets to come in they're
not gonna have open borders you still
just say like who's who's ahead in line
to get the more sort of anti-immigrant
forces on board with this these people
are saying well these laws seem a little
bit liberal to us I mean we don't want
people from asian-african all these
other people so what if we to restrict
that we just sort of said if you're
already here and you have a family
member who's you know your sister your
parent who wants to come that person can
come and they have priority and if we do
that everyone's European here that will
keep the immigrants more or less
European this we now know of as chain
migration right the Trump administration
talks about this all the time or family
reunification what they don't anticipate
is that that is the very mechanism that
accelerates non-whites immigration
because it turns out that most of the
Europeans who wanted to come here we're
kind of already here great so it it
wasn't helping I mean I you know it
wasn't helping
we're gonna bring Grandma or a great
aunt from you know county quark over it
grant turns into something
and you have to remember in 1965
immigration history in the u.s. is
European you know we can't fathom
immigration coming from around the world
the way we do people flying into JFK
Airport because we can't that's not our
view if you think of immigration you
think oh it's European immigration what
they what people don't notice is that
even already by night the mid-1960s
you're seeing more Asian immigration
than before it's very very low levels
compared to now but you know we have
refugee loves there letting people in
during the Vietnam War right we begin to
allow more Asian immigrants during the
Cold War so little by little there are
more Asian immigrants coming in and once
you have family reunification that
number really begins to explode but a
lot of its just understanding that if
you're someone in 1965 immigration is
European we've always been a European
country and so that's why they don't
really foresee how these laws are going
to just transform American demographics
and there is fewer immigration
immigrants right in 1970 the percentage
of foreign-born population is under 5%
it's the lowest amount that it's ever
been because immigration was stopped
both by world events but especially by
immigration policy so it seemed there's
more kind of room to give because if
it's only 5% of the population as
opposed to 15 you know what's a couple
more you know people non-english
speaking exactly it's a symbolic idea
right and it's also that then this idea
of again of a nation of immigrants is a
mythology from the past in a way right
it's not a going concern because when
you cut off immigration the way we did
in the 20s I mean the number is just
plummet and so essentially all these
immigrants who come in from Easter they
almost assimilate more deeply into being
white Americans and right now right we
don't think of in the 20s if you're
retiring or Jewish you're considered not
quite white and now we take for granted
the people you know they're all
considered white but all of that it that
sort of consolidation of whiteness is
happening during this time too so
there's odd paradoxes going on too as
the percentage of foreign-born shrinks
people feel more comfortable asserting
an ethnic identity as being you know
what makes you American is not that
you're on the Mayflower but it said oh
I'm an italian-american or I'm a black
african-american I mean Native American
after 1970 things start to explode again
the number of immigrants or percentage
of the population foreign so it's
growing especially from places like
Mexico explain where how does Mexico fit
into all of this because it is odd like
we talked about Asia and Europe and
Mexico Mexicans actually had a free rein
coming in and out of the country up
until the mid 60 yeah Mexican
immigration is wildly different from how
we think of it today essentially had
open borders you know we had a literacy
test on all of our borders but really if
you could again physically make that
journey and get your two feet onto US
soil you were fine
yeah no visas no long waiting lists
people could just come and again it's
part of our foreign policy so the idea
is in the Western Hemisphere we have all
these neighbors it would be insulting or
not very neighborly to have restrictions
and so there are no quotas there are no
numerical limitations even through the
1920s for that all that restriction on
Europe and Asia Western Hemisphere is
just totally open we don't we don't have
any limits essentially and so if you
want to there's no limit on how many
little from Mexico can come the 1960s
come around and this becomes part of the
debate which is what do we do we have
this whole system in place for outside
the Western Hemisphere right we have
quotas we have a numerical cap we're
gonna get rid of these sort of this
racist ranking of people but we're still
gonna have a numerical cap but what
about the Western Hemisphere why do we
treat that differently and some of the
more anti-immigrant people said
essentially well that seems
discriminatory in a funny way to have
one set of rules for the Western
Hemisphere and another for Europe and
the rest of the world and so they then
add a numerical cap for the very first
time on immigration from other countries
in the Western Hemisphere including
Mexico an overnight that changes how we
think about immigrants from Mexico right
suddenly there's a numerical cap which
means that there's a lot more room for
illegal immigration so suddenly things
that were considered perfectly legal and
normal take on this label of illegal and
may 9 as historians and a lot of work on
this so yeah one of one of the things
that is kind of hard to understand is
that the government can assert a law
but you know you're talking about a kind
of arbitrary border and people don't
stop coming simply because it's you know
it's within or without the law so
starting in you know in the 70s and into
the 80s because this becomes big issue
under Ronald Reagan there's a huge
influx of Mexicans in particular as well
as Asian emigrants how does this you
know what what happens as you know once
the 1965 Act and that is put into place
and we start seeing a ramp up again of
immigration how did Ronald Reagan deal
with immigration he basically has a the
last major truly ambitious reworking of
American immigration laws comes into
Reagan and he basically creates a path
to citizenship for all these people he
creates amnesty and that is supposed to
basically try to I mean everyone was
always trying to solve immigration once
and for all this is his passive that of
course that doesn't quite work I'd argue
the next pass at this under Bill Clinton
is at least as transformative I think in
the moment it wasn't considered as
ambitious as what Reagan did but Bill
Clinton is the one who really creates
this idea of I would argue for a
perpetual state of illegal immigration
crisis because he narrows he both
narrows the pathways to citizenship and
increases the reasons to deport people
and so you put that all together and you
basically keep changing the rules so
that fewer people can come and stay and
more people can be deported which again
if you look at the history we don't we
just weren't deporting people right so
if you come here and you make a life
here no one is coming into your door and
saying you're out of here that's again a
very modern constant and to go first
Reagan and then let's talk about Clinton
because we're we're living in the long
shadow of that yeah
Reagan there's I mean there's tremendous
footage from 1980 debate between George
HW Bush and Ronald Reagan where they're
debating in Houston their sole slugging
it out for the Republican nomination and
there's a debate where they are outdoing
each other of who would be more
welcoming to illegal immigrants who they
have they say are part of absolutely
part of American culture the work force
we need to be welcome and then it's like
you know
it's like from an alternate timeline and
man in the high castle or something
Reagan over night times legislation that
ultimately allows millions of illegals
to enter the country with some
restrictions because that's you know
that it becomes harder for workers
rather employers to employ illegals like
there are sanctions but against that but
things kind of set there then in the mid
nineties and you know you're talking
about Bill Clinton like illegal
immigration becomes a big big issue and
he responds by making it easier to
deport people yes and this whole idea of
law enforcement and immigration you know
it's really just ramping up more and
more and more right because again if we
step back basically an open border with
Mexico no visas no passports you've
every successive stage right in the last
100 years we keep adding bureaucracy
paperwork more and more restrictions and
so not only to who can come in but we
say you can be deported too right you
you even if you show up and you've been
here for a long time you have a family
here we can come in and say you need to
leave right now and that is all
relatively new and that you know that
built up under george w bush who was
actually rhetorically was extremely
friendly to immigrants and he did you
know in 2004 he had two big agenda items
after winning reelection one was Social
Security privatization and the other was
immigration reform he got his ass kicked
by everybody but especially is own party
Barack Obama deported even more people
by any measure than George Bush did what
is going on with that like because
nothing you know both I mean neither
these guys seem to be like oh we're
xenophobic Bush was the first president
and I don't know we like ever who spoke
Spanish she was governor of Texas he
welcomed illegal immigrants as part of
the workforce yeah what's what's going
on I mean I think part of it is that we
are not grappling with how much our
immigration has changed I mean again if
we think about the history it's all
European its assimilation it's the sort
of gauzy nation remember gran
what we haven't I think really grappled
with is the question of race on
immigration
just how non-white all this immigration
is and I think that again when you say
Don white it's you know if if Mexicans
aren't considered white in another 20 or
30 years something is will be very
strange because they're I mean but it is
true so that the sources of immigration
comes starting to come from Latin
America and then from Asia including
India yeah this this is the issue you
think that I think part of it is that we
we we don't always understand that the
immigration we're seeing now is just
just as in the 20s the the Italians who
came and the Russian Jews who came
seemed really different right they
didn't just look different they
worshiped differently they ate different
food they dressed differently
I think their that when that happens
there's room for a lot of nativists to
say hey who are these people they don't
speak English they're not like us
they're different can they assimilate
it's the same questions of assimilation
but unlike previous generations where
the assimilation was from Europeans
these are people from around the world
these are many many more countries
coming in
yeah and now the I mean the main people
main sending countries really are China
or from Asia including India that yes
then from even Latin America much less
Europe fastest growing racial group
right now is Asian American and so all
of this is happening and I don't know if
I don't know that people aren't
necessarily sensing that you know in a
statistical way that they know it but I
think that that if someone wants to make
a xenophobic argument there's room to do
that
because if you look around our country
is really changing pretty dramatically
and you add you know a financial crisis
and economic instability all these
things put together I'd argue make it
easier for there to be anti-immigrant
policies it makes it easier to say we
need to deport people we need to sort of
crackdown because there's this other
right these people are coming and
they're the other and need to be treated
in a certain way and we need to be tough
on them and tough on crime and all of
that I think both Democrats and
Republicans have embraced and to your
point like as recently as the eighties
we were still acting very welcoming and
I'd also add a lot of employers have
always wanted immigrants I mean they are
a huge I haven't mentioned this but
in all these debates the big farms out
in the southwest all of companies are
always saying open up the borders open
because they want this sort of cheaper
labor at all time we started by talking
about your personal connection in this
yeah let's end with that so you
mentioned that not even everybody in
your you know kind of extended family as
pro-immigrant how do how does your
family talk about american-ness and is
it how linked is it to being white or
not or you know where where is that
conversation going because one of the
things where you know in this super woke
moment where in a way it would seem the
cruelest thing you could do because you
know one one noisy rhetoric is that
America is the most extremely racist
country in the world like why would you
ever want to bring somebody from you
know Myanmar here because then they
would really experience awful repression
but I you know what is the conversation
that's playing at a you know in your
family discussions of this I think I
mean we've always thought of my so the
parents my parents and my aunts and
uncles who came or you know they're like
the ones who made the journey right and
I think you know they love this country
and we've all kind of adopted this idea
that this country took us in allowed us
to really make our lives here and I
think that they look at Trump's rhetoric
and they are nervous about it because it
seems like we thought that this country
wanted immigrants and suddenly we seem
to not want them at the same time I
think you know like a lot of immigrant
families I don't know that my family has
a very clear sense of well who should be
allowed after we've come in right like
should people at the border be allowed
in these circumstances you know I think
there's also the sense of like we
followed these rules some people aren't
following the rules for me what I
learned from this book essentially is
that the rules keep changing and so this
idea that you follow the rules are your
family followed the rules your
grandparents did and now this person
isn't I'm not sure that's a fair
comparison because if you just look at
how much we've transformed the entire
sort of government infrastructure around
immigration it doesn't remotely resemble
probably what your parents or
grandparents or great-grandparents went
through and for me I mean I've talked my
parents our parents didn't know any of
this
history either and so I think I hope
this is a little bit of a wake-up call
for people whose families have come more
recently that essentially you know your
family was allowed here but it's only
because of these political struggles and
these laws and people have to fight for
them and in a way they're kind of
inadvertently allowing your family and
because they didn't plan on letting in
these many Asian Americans but all this
is changing all the time it's subject to
change right as we learn in Nazi Germany
unfortunately one day you can be a
citizen the next day you're not a
citizen these are all legal categorical
and when Reagan flips that from one day
you're an illegal immigrant the next day
you're a citizen right who's to say that
you know you will always be legal
permanently you and your family and
who's to say that you will be illegal
right so I think we tend to in our
debates treat these labels is very fixed
and immutable both historically and just
sort of legally like this is the law but
what I learned from doing this book is
that the laws are changing all the time
we could we decide as a democracy who
can be a citizen who can enter the
country and we can rewrite those laws
all over again and we have right we've
gone from very open borders to not open
borders at all we're in the middle of
doing that now with the Trump White
House right they're trying to reduce not
just illegal but legal immigration and
green card visas and we might see
demographic changes all over again but
essentially all of this is fluid none of
it is fixed and we should all I imagine
I think we should think of all of our
families as being part of this very
changing idea of how much we are a
nation of immigrants in the two months
following my conversation with yang
there have been early signs that the
kovat 19 pandemic could have a major
effect on US immigration policy
including Trump's executive order
temporarily halting legal migration a
delay in asylum hearings on the Mexican
border and a Centers for Disease Control
and Prevention order blocking entry of
migrant children that invokes at 1940s
era law I started by asking yang whether
she thinks kovat 19 will have a long
lasting impact on immigration policy
why has the corona virus lockdown made a
book about immigration of all things
more relevant than it would have
before right because none of us are
traveling anywhere migrating anywhere
it's quite the opposite so I think
there's at least two reasons one early
on that struck me was you know because
this virus was being called the Chinese
virus by the president it immediately
had this sort of ethnic racial quality
to it and that would then immediately
set off a lot of xenophobia and in fact
their xenophobia all around the world
from this pandemic but in the u.s. that
version of xenophobia is specifically
anti-asian and we've seen people of
everything from you know they're
standing in law agen american standing
line at the grocery store mining their
own business getting supplies like
everybody else needs and someone's
saying something racist to them people
being physically attacked spat on you
know children being bullied and being
called a Chinese virus so that
immediately began happening in March
there were reports of this so this
really for me revealed kind of a tenuous
political standing of Asian Americans
yet again and this idea of Asian
Americans part of America and this whole
story in history of how there came to be
so many Asian Americans in this country
in the first place and to me the missing
piece in that conversation which sort of
goes around and around in circles is you
have to understand the history of how
all these Asian immigrants came here to
begin with to understand I would argue
why our political position is so tenuous
because the 1965 law right it's almost
like a backdoor entry it wasn't
explicitly designed to admit this many
Asian immigrants and yet here all of us
are and everyone feels done everyone but
like many people feel like oh we've
assimilated we fit in and it takes a
xenophobic moment like this to remind
everyone oh wait a second
I stole look Asian I still don't really
fit in I'm still considered foreign
what's going on there and I just think
you can't really answer that question
without knowing the literal like
political history of why there's so many
Asian Americans that's the first reason
okay do you think this has calls back to
HAP's previous moments of xenophobia you
know against German Americans or German
things in America during it would have
been the Spanish flu pandemic of 1918
1919 in World War one so the closest
analogy that I've come across is the
bubonic plague scare from the early
1900's so when this hit this is
physically in San Francisco this was
where the fear was concentrated this was
of course after the Congress had already
passed the Chinese Exclusion Act of 1882
but there was still a very you know very
robust Chinatown community in San
Francisco and the plague immediately
became associated with Chinese
immigrants and it played on all these
stereotypes about Chinese immigrants
being dirty being unhygenic unsanitary
and the city responded in an
extraordinary racists way they basically
um you know forced these communities
under lockdown they began to force
people to get vaccinations which during
this time were you know this is a very
early time for vaccination they were
really terrifying to get they weren't
the way that we get them now just a
simple shot and they banned people from
leaving Chinese immigrants from leaving
their communities without getting
vaccinated so there was actually a court
case about this and a federal judge said
you can't actually this violates the
14th amendment you can't forcibly
vaccinate people and prevent them from
leaving their neighborhood this is this
is illegal but it really unleashed this
incredibly specifically anti-asian
backlash and it wrapped in all these
stereotypes of you know these immigrants
and there was already anti-immigration
laws pertaining to Chinese people but
the plague and the fear of it certainly
exacerbated all that do you do you think
that the corona virus then will have a
direct and immediate effect on
immigration policy you're talking about
a kind of cultural moment now whenever
Congress fully gets back to operating
and whatnot do you think it'll it'll be
on the legislative agenda to change
immigration policy I do and I think you
know I can't predict that but I think
that there
of reasons to think that that's more
possible now so the first would be you
already see the Trump White House
through executive order taking pretty
dramatic action right Trump has already
suspended temporarily for now family
based immigration they're not issuing
you green cards they haven't tampered
with the temporary worker visa situation
because you know our farms depend on
that like there's too much affected but
really and and there are so since there
also seems to be some interest in having
more foreign medical where medical care
workers or health care workers coming
right from certain areas of workers we
want but sort of the core like legal
immigration especially the chain
migration that Stephen Miller is really
against that that part of our legal
immigration system he's already told
conservative supporters we're using the
this pandemic as a pretext to advance
our broader immigration agenda and I
think that not only is that going to
have more traction because of the anti
Asian fears and xenophobia the fact that
this virus originated can but also the
economy so we know from our history that
when our economy really takes a turn for
the worse and that is a wild
understatement as to what we're going
through now there's an immediate turn to
saying well how do we protect our
American workers we've got to get rid of
immigrants so you look at the Great
Depression which you know we could we
are already a Great Depression levels
you could argue in some states like
Nevada we're already at twenty five
percent unemployment and there's no sign
of it ending you know during the Great
Depression Hoover did mass deportations
of Mexican immigrants and american-born
Mexican Americans and that was you know
it didn't didn't do anything to help the
economy there's no you know deporting
people are is not going to bring back
jobs we have a pandemic that's why
people don't have jobs but that was an
easy thing to argue for politically
because if you're worried about your job
if you're worried about competition you
know the administration can clearly
argue and Republicans can argue anyone
who wants to anti-immigration say look
it's not race it's the economy we can't
we can't spare you know we can't have
this competition here we need to help
our kids get jobs again and look at
those immigrants you know they pose an
economic threat so I just say between
just the like you know the the inherent
xenophobia that a global pandemic can
unleash there is the economic argument
that you could make now to saying our
economy simply can't afford to have as
many immigrants could you perhaps
compare contrast the current moment to
that moment in the early 20s when the
restriction estaphan Oh lock down the
borders finally we're able to pass it in
the in the teens and 20s people were
much less timid about being openly
racist but they also oftentimes did try
to make larger arguments than simple
basic kind of xenophobia racism now it's
you know it's hard to do that do you
think we'll see an open to kind of open
racism as a result of this I think
actually the the people in the 20s who
argued for it were in some ways quite
sophisticated and how they you know
supported because they're good arguments
supporting these ethnic quotas they
already in the 20s knew that they would
be called racist and we're called racist
and took offense to that and so their
argument which I think you see white
nationalist right out all the time and I
think it's a very sophisticated argue
we're more sophisticated than just
saying I'm right this would be to say
I'm not racist I'm not saying that some
races are inferior or superior to others
I just want to keep AMERICA AMERICA
implication being I want to keep America
white and anglo-saxon so you know Jews
Jews are fine Chinese people are fine I
don't have anything wrong with them but
they need to stay with their people and
we need to keep our people a certain way
so I think if you look over the years
every time there's a nativist you know
debate around you know should we allow
people of this ethnicity here or not
there is this way that the people who
support the nativist will say like I'm
not I'm not racist I'm just saying let's
keep things homogeneous let's keep
stability right that's another word that
we have to keep our democracy stable
introducing foreign elements is a
destabilizing force and we shouldn't do
that and so I think in a moment like
this again you better argue we can't
just imagine you can make this nativist
argument right and not sound quite as
overtly racist you could say well we've
got a pandemic our economy is in
freefall our society is coming apart the
seams we simply just can't afford to
take in people who you know they could
say don't speak English they don't have
money when they come they're gonna be a
burden our social welfare so yeah you
can make you can imagine making all
these arguments that don't you know
again don't sound overtly racist and
when a society is under pressure the way
we are now you could you can imagine a
lot of Americans sort of nodding along
saying yeah now is not the time for more
immigrants you do you think that labor
and some elements of the Democratic
Party you know I wouldn't say that the
Republican Party is is openly racist and
it's when it when it is anti-immigrant
and obviously there's a section of the
Republican Party that has always been
very Pro immigrant but does the economic
argument now or the economic reality
you're right you know the economy is
shrinking we don't know how far we know
you know we're looking at conceivably 10
or 20 percent unemployment nationally do
you think that's going to embolden
you know maybe more Democratic Party or
left-wing populist to flex against
immigration
I don't really know honestly I mean it's
a good question because I think the
Democratic Party generally has just been
incredibly muddled on immigration I I
could not tell you what Joe Biden's
platform is on this I mean I think the
Democratic Party for a while is just
under Trump is just said we don't want
to separate families that's inhumane we
love immigrants we're not racist that's
kind of a pitch I I don't see them I
mean you saw who Leon Castro you know in
his short-lived campaign I think
actually put forward a pretty ambitious
full full-throated immigration policy
platform but I haven't really seen it
from the Biden campaign or the
Democratic Party leadership in Congress
so I don't really know and I think I
think the left-wing populist I mean
I think they're gonna you know what
they've been arguing for for a while now
right is a new deal style policy
platform and they were already arguing
for that before the pandemic you're
hearing it again I don't know none of
that is gaining traction on the hill for
all the dollar dollar amounts of these
stimulus packages three German yeah
we've got like three trillion dollars
and new spending and nobody really quite
knows where it's going exactly this is
not whatever it is it's not the New Deal
back to Leo so I imagine the left is
gonna keep arguing for return to the New
Deal just as they were already doing
people like you know Alexander Acacio
Cortes people who were trying to revive
that part of the Democratic Party
tradition and I just I don't think they
thought through how to deal with
immigration to I mean again Hoover you
know infamously failed to help the
country during the Great Depression
right he deported Mexicans that did
nothing obviously to help the economy
with the economy needed was you know
Keynesian stimulus of money that's well
well we'll argue about whether it aided
Keynesian stimulus but definitely
definitely it needed more in terms of
demand you're not you're not gonna grow
demand by getting rid of people exactly
so again we are and the demand that's
coming is not real demand it appears to
be something of a giveaway that sort of
slipping through his fingers no one can
no one who needs the money is getting it
very few on the great small businesses
and then immigration you know they can
turn to that as a boogeyman so it does
do a little bit like the earlier moments
of the Great Depression where no one
quite knew how to respond one of the one
of the large points of your book and and
in art you know at our original
interview which wasn't that long ago but
it does seem like it took place on
another planet really but you you noted
that the changing of the immigration
rules and laws in 1965 was primarily a
function of elites it wasn't there was
no groundswell of you know we you know
among the people demanding politicians
change this and there wasn't even much
discussion or understanding or kind of
fisken of what the implications would be
do
you think any changes to immigration
policy now will those be driven by
populist you know well that will it be
bottom up or will it be top down it's a
good question I think you know one
reason why it used to be more top-down
I'd argue is because foreign policy was
much it was a much bigger part of it so
during the Cold War presidents one
person natural are both Democrats and
Republicans you know Harry Truman Dwight
Eisenhower LBJ JMT they all felt like
during the Cold War in an ideological
battle where the US was supposed to be
you know a greater moral force in the
Soviet Union this immigration law the
quota system was just immoral and
indefensible and therefore a foreign
policy liability and you could see all
the refugee laws right that were passed
and the carve-outs from executive orders
for certain you know like the Cuban
refugees right those were all those were
all immigration steps taken to advance
American foreign policy ideas and now
that foreign policy I rarely hear about
it as part of our domestic debate it
feels very driven by you know domestic
racial politics economic fears you don't
really hear someone saying whoa whoa
whoa we can't defend you know in Latin
America because that is against our
foreign policy but I I don't even hear
Democrats thinking that argument I mean
who leaned Castro again actually did
kind of bring foreign policy into it but
I I haven't heard anyone do that in a
long time
otherwise so I do think because of that
I imagine the forces shaping our
immigration policy have already felt to
me more bottom-up because even though
Trump is the one kind of exerting it for
executive order to me he's reading the
cues of his supporters right he's
playing to his rally crowds he's playing
to I think an environment of fear around
immigration around our economy and the
stability of our society so I don't
think that there is a groundswell of
anti-immigration feeling in this country
if you look at polling actually most
Americans feel like immigrants make the
country better but I think there's just
enough of an element from the bottom up
kind of egging on Trump that he feeds
off of too that he's responding to that
versus you know a sense of too
clonus II or America's place in the
world which is you know in my reading in
the 20th century that's a lot of what
presidents were responding to for the
immigrants who stay here how does that
affect their were their sense of
american-ness and do they you know is is
there a predictable response kind of a
large response to that do they become
more American do they try to be super
American or do they become kind of
exiles in in their new home country this
has come up in the whole debate about
how to respond to the age anti-asian
xenophobia so I'll just take off that
piece of it I mean Andrew yang the
former presidential candidate we're not
been in the Washington Post that was
widely criticized but the argument
basically was we are now held under
suspicion by our fellow citizens and the
best way to deal with that is to become
more American essentially to show that
we're really American by being part of
the solution but pandemic you know
really just showing that we love this
country we're not foreign and strange
we're not a threat we're here to we're
here to help and I think there's a
there's a long history of Asian
Americans trying to do that to me the
most fascinating would be after the
japanese-americans were placed in
internment camps during World War two
people literally volunteered to die in
World War two to prove that they
belonged and that moment actually
dovetails with immigration history oddly
enough so when they come back this was a
time when Asian Americans Japanese
Americans could not naturalize become
citizens they were also practically all
but banned from entering the country and
so people leverage activists Asian
actors leveraged the sacrifices World
War Two to win naturalization rights for
all Asian immigrants which you know was
a huge watershed moment for for Asian
Americans and to secure more immigration
slots for Asians than had existed before
so that moment happened but I do feel
like once you've been on the road of
we're gonna prove that we're more
American I think that's a never-ending
kind of path to go down and I do think
what's interesting now about our country
our number graphics is that you could
argue that jus
Americans Italian Americans I every
European immigrant group that comes
right everyone whose families from here
every ethnic group at some point
assimilated right into to be specific
what that means into being considered
white Americans yet most of the
immigrants we have now are not European
you know they really don't look white
like my family we don't look like that's
that's not what we look like so what
does assimilation look like then and I
think we were already wrestling with
that it's still a very new phenomenon
that we have this many non-european
immigrants I don't know how far we were
with that but I can't imagine that
academic and the threat of social
collapse is gonna make you gonna make
that easier although it's true that in
moments of crisis and disaster
communities do come together so I think
there are these cross currents and it's
just I you know and I I think when I
look back on and I think about my own
parents were children of immigrants who
grew up during the Depression my father
fought in World War two as an Irish
immigrant there's no question that that
participating in large numbers in World
War two helped kind of make you know
Irish and attend my my old one of my
uncle's fought who was a firstborn
generation born in America fought in the
invasion of Italy and so he's able to
come back and say look I you know I I'm
an American yeah yeah and then on top of
that so you have that kind of traumatic
moment that actually allows people to
you know put their life on the line to
become American and then you have a
basically uninterrupted economic boom so
that the pie is getting bigger for
everybody and I don't think we have
either of those situations right now
right and lower yeah and right we are
literally socially isolated so I don't
see you know I can see virtually but
people are trying to help each other
people are getting their horns are
coming out and banging in a pot but I
don't I'm not like shoulders or shoulder
with fellow Americans in the trenches of
fighting the pandemic and I think to
come back to my earlier point I mean we
have just a total economic collapse on
our hands I mean people are already
going hungry I just don't think we can
over
just how catastrophic that site of it is
I mean we are living through the Great
Depression of some kind the only
question is will it be worse than the
Great Depression in the thirties and I
don't think I can't point to an incident
in American history at least where
financial and economic collapse led to
you know a come by oscillating where
everyone is like oh you're different
from me that's okay you know we can
either all in it together yeah that's I
mean once you remove certainty
instability and you introduce a sense
that you know essentially with this
economic collapse to me what's striking
is how son-in it was right it's like
everyone is going about their business
and then the sky just Falls and nothing
could be more I think just sort of
destabilizing I mean your sense of the
Sun will come up every day like that is
just taken away and I think once people
have that fear that they're not in
control that no one is in control right
they're not in control the government
has not I mean their leaders have not
stepped in to make them feel like things
are under control I just think when
there's that sense of uncertainty fear
just you know the idea that we don't
know what tomorrow will bring I think
that those are conditions that in my
mind seem very ripe for more xenophobia
not less well I am let's I hate to end
on that kind of note but I think it's a
powerful punctuation point we've been
talking with Gio Linh yang she is Nash
deputy national editor at the New York
Times and the author of the new book and
even more relevant book than it was when
I guess when you delivered the
manuscript Jill and one mighty and
irresistible tide the epic struggle over
American immigration 1924 to 1965 thanks
for talking with me for an addendum to
the original interview we did it was my
pleasure thanks des
you